[Music]
though japan
is nothing but an island in the world a
benevolent rule has been conducted since
the emperor jimmu
founded the country no other foreign
country
can compare with japan in terms of the
abundance of grains grown
therefore there is none among those
japanese who were wrecked abroad
and drifted to a foreign country that
did not yearn
for their native traditions and to
return home
manjiro and the other japanese castaways
were washed upon an uninhabited island
in the year of the ox of tempo they
journeyed to the sandwich islands
north america and other foreign lands
suffering many hardships and toiling day
and night for more than ten years
they attempted to return to japan
and finally fulfilled their wish in the
year of the rat
of kai they are indeed what i call
people who yearn after the country and
its origins
in the 12th year of tempo the year of
the ox
five fishermen set out to fish in the
nearby sea
four of the young japanese men were from
nishihama
the fifth manjiro 15 was from nakanohama
village
in hatta county they borrowed a small
boat about 24 feet long
and loaded it with one and a half
bushels of rice firewood
water and kindling sailing from uso aura
harbour at about 10
in the morning of the fifth day of
january they headed west
at about 10 o'clock in the morning the
wind shifted
the clouds moved swiftly overhead seeing
this
the other boats quickly unfurled their
sails and headed toward nunozaki
fudinojo ordered the crew to haul in the
fishing gear and set sail for land
about 18 miles away working together
they raced towards land as the sun set
waves splashed and sprayed all around
them making it impossible to see ahead
then a north easterly wind rose and the
two currents fought against each other
threatening to overturn the boat several
times
soon the situation grew desperate as the
oar lock for the sculling oar broke off
exhausted overwhelmed with fatigue they
were at a loss
though everyone was devoted to his duty
the wind became stronger and the
temperatures grew colder
they were freezing and only fudinojo
held the helm
the boat was swept swiftly like an arrow
in a south-east direction
they drifted into the night
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so as we all know coco is the world's
biggest japan
nerd she loves japan and is absolutely
devastated she can't visit this here
she loves sushi she loves amana miyaki
she loves she loves eating the christmas
tree
so if you're feeling claustrophobic like
me and coco japan from above in 4k
is the documentary for you a beautiful
journey around the land of the rising
sun
replete with lots of incredible vistas
and at the moment magellan has an
amazing two for one gift card deal
so there really isn't a better time to
try out and share the more than 3 000
documentaries magellan offers
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers
and also to get involved in the great
two-for-one gift card deal
[Music]
thanks
on the early morning of the 10th the
winds shifted in their favor
and rain began to fall they covered
their boat with rush matting split wood
prepared some gruel and ate it with fish
then the rain turned to sleet and they
gathered it in their palms
satisfying their thirst
around noon on the 13th day they caught
a dim view of a small island in the
southeast direction
their provisions exhausted they were
unbearably hungry and thirsty
they felt hopeless if what they saw
ahead was truly an island
they would go ashore to obtain water
take an ample sip
and willingly throw themselves into the
sea to end
their misery once everyone was ashore
some of the men walked around the island
to find its shape
it was a large craggy island about two
and a half miles in diameter
a cave gate to nearby the castaways
crept in on their bellies to find the
cave was about nine by 15 feet square
the hungry crew ate some birds and took
shelter
in the cave
one day while manjiro was gathering
shellfish on the shore
he saw two boats being lowered from a
foreign ship and heading for the island
with sails unfurled
he cried out to his mates rescuers
rescuers the rescue boats are coming
hearing this torremon and gomon ran
forward and tied gomond's trousers to a
broken sail yard
holding them up as a distress signal the
crewmen raised their hats
in response
as they approached the ship and looked
up fudinojo and the others
were aghast bewildered by this sudden
rescue
and halfway between sleeping and waking
the ship was about 30
ken long and six ken wide with three
masts and eight small boats on deck
they were brought inside the ship to the
captain's quarters here they saw a row
of rooms furnished
gorgeously enough to serve as a small
shrine for buddha
the rooms looked so dignified that the
castaways were ored and could hardly
approach them
they knelt in fear before the captain
and his mates
the captain told fujinojo and the others
to come close and said something
incomprehensible imagining they were
being asked what nationality they were
they answered nihonjin nihon jin
taking pity on their cold and hunger the
captain took out five suits of dry
clothes
and showed them by gestures how to wear
them
the cook brought them some steamed sweet
potatoes which the captain disapproved
of perhaps he thought it was unwise for
the five men to suddenly eat a lot of
food
he took back their food and gave them
bowls of herb soup and a little pork
thereafter the captain gave them solid
food gradually
for lunch the crew seemed to eat another
kind of food while the men were served
good rice the captain perhaps guessing
they were japanese
they appreciated the captain's
consideration and enjoyed
the meals the big ship was a whale ship
from
new bedford massachusetts from the
united states in north america
on board were six thousand oil barrels
several cows and hogs grain
two cannons and thirty bayonets
it was manned by 34 men and was called
the john
james howland the captain was william
h whitfield a native of fairhaven a town
bordering new bedford
he was about 40 years old fair of skin
jet black hair trimmed and combed
straight back
he was wearing a jacket and what looked
like a close-fitting coat called
trousers or pantaloons he was nearly six
feet tall and looked like a nobleman
though fudinojo and the others didn't
know what would become of them after
being saved by the foreigners
they were relieved but now they were
being kept alive
and their means of returning home would
present itself
in due course
one day in november the ship entered the
port at oahu
one of the sandwich islands after
fujinojo and the others settled down
captain whitfield had five jackets and
five pairs of trousers made for them
and gave them five half dollars each the
ship's company
also gave them five overcoats the
captain
told fujinojo and the others that now
they had settled down
they must live in peace then he asked
for fujinojo's permission to take
manjiro
to america and educate him he thought
that the boy learned quickly and showed
great promise
he said he would treat manjiro well
fudinojo was dismayed with the idea that
after drifting to such a distant foreign
land they might have to live separately
against their wishes
he didn't want them to be separated
they'd been through so much adversity
together
on the other hand captain whitfield was
very kind
and had saved their lives as the request
grew out of the affection and
admiration the captain felt for the boy
the decision rested with manjiro
fudinojo gave his permission
this pleased captain whitfield very much
he took
manjiro with him and returned to the
ship
in november the 12th year of tempo the
year of the ox
manjiro parted from fudinojo and the
others
and accompanied captain whitfield on his
travels at sea
he was called john mung or mung
for short and he became part of the crew
in early december they set sail from
oahu and headed south
they came upon the volcanic island
called hurricane island
where the castaways had experienced such
hardships together
the men fished for small fish near the
island and then caught some whales in
waters about
120 to 250 miles of japan
by late april in the 14th year of tempo
the year of the hare
they had sailed to within 250 miles of
cape
horn the southern tip of south america
the sea turned icy and numerous large
icebergs towered high around them
they passed the highest and largest one
which measured over one
thousand feet and appeared to topple
over
a strange ocean animal the size of a
large bull was found here
and was known as a sea horse
seals passed by here too odd and
colorful with dark red backs and horns
at the top of their muzzles
all heading northeast the men also saw
a strange star called a comet
that filled the western sky it was said
to appear
every 80 to 100 years
the ship headed due north northwest and
it reached the entrance of new
bedford harbour in early june
new bedford was located in the province
of massachusetts
in the united states in north america
the city's harbour was more than six
miles long
and its entrance at its narrowest was
over two miles wide
after informing the owner of the ship's
return captain whitfield parted from the
crew
taking manjiro with him he crossed the
bridge to the south side
and arrived in the village of fairhaven
which was second to new bedford in
number of streets
thoroughfares and houses captain
whitfield's house was located in the
middle
of town when he reached home the front
door was tightly shut
and the house looked desolated and
dilapidated
very worried he knocked at the house
next door and asked why his house looked
abandoned
captain whitfield learned that his wife
had died while he was at sea
and that because there was no other
family members to occupy it
the house was closed up devastated
he took manjiro to the home of james
allen a carpenter
who gave manjiro lodging
the country of the united states was
more than 6930 re
from east to west and more than 4 100
from north to south it was divided into
more than
30 provinces because the country was
located at 40 to 50 degrees north
latitude
the air was clean and the temperature
was seasonable and a variety
of grains grew there the natives were
extremely lovely in appearance
with fair skin and dark hair they were
more than
five or six feet tall kind and gentle by
nature
both affectionate and compassionate they
thought highly of morality and fidelity
and were always diligent and industrious
in everything
including trading far and wide
needless to say the women were lovely
and bundled their dark hair at the crown
they were never seen wearing ornamental
hairpins
their nature was obedient and it had
become the custom of the country for
women to be
highly virtuous there were all sorts of
people including those with
dark skin red hair and a slightly
different disposition
probably the results of the blending of
different races
food clothes houses and tools were the
same as in oahu
but oahu could not compare with fair
haven in terms
of opulence as in oahu people disdained
liquor but those who were idle and
permissive would indulge
these people were especially avoided as
nobody dared approach them
manjiro was now boarded in the house of
james allen for several days
allen's daughter jane who was over 30
taught a number of children at an
elementary school in the neighborhood
miss allen told manjiro that if you
wanted to learn how to write
she would teach him and bought him a
copy book so he studied
earnestly meanwhile captain whitfield
visited a city called
new york in the province of new york
located 250 miles from fairhaven it was
the seat of administration for more than
30 provinces
for their government people elected a
man of wisdom
and learning for president who held
office for four years
however if the man were highly virtuous
and enlightened and governed the people
eminently they allowed him to remain in
office
the income per year for the president
was one thousand two hundred silver
pieces
silver coin is equivalent to japanese
two can
500 men of talent assembled in the
capital from far and wide
and competed to be elected to the office
the current
president is called taylor he was said
to be just in
administering punishment justice and law
because the country was governed in such
a way the people would say the united
states
was better than any other in the world
[Music]
manjiro was ready for his next adventure
[Music]
he had heard that in a united states
province called california
a great gold mine was located within the
limits of sacramento
people who went there from other
provinces were at liberty to dig
for gold if he went to california to be
a digger manjiro thought he would surely
get hold of extraordinary wealth
and would then be free to do as he
pleased perhaps
he could earn his passage to japan which
was his dream
taking his old acquaintance terry with
him they took passage on a ship
anchored in fair haven called stiglitz
which was 130 feet
in length
[Music]
in may they reached california and
docked in san francisco
which was an important resting place for
trading vessels
the thriving city was located on the
hills behind the bay
and over 3 000 closely packed houses
lined the streets
the two companies put up at a hotel for
three days and took passage on a strange
ship
called a steamboat
[Music]
at night they journeyed up a big river
for more than 260 miles
and reached sacramento
after landing they saw many strange
vehicles called
railroads there were very many such
vehicles in the united states
manjiro said that he had ridden one
before
the railroad ran on coal an 18 square
foot iron box enclosed a strong coal
fire and the accumulated steam was
released through an iron pipe
the steam turned the wheels and
propelled the massive vehicle
at high speed turning exactly the same
way
as the wheels of a steamboat
people settled in a box put their
possessions on the rack above and sat
beneath
they could look at scenery out the
windows three on the right side three on
the left
all fitted with glass if you looked out
the windows
all things slanted sideways and it ran
so fast that nothing remained in sight
for long
it was a rare sight the railroad's path
lay where there were no mountains
and iron rods were laid on the ground
without a break for hundreds of miles
so that the railroad could run over them
hiking for five days they climbed a high
mountain half covered with snow
called sierra nevada
when they arrived they immediately went
to work manjiro was employed during the
day by the gold agency
as a miner and was given digging tools a
large pit was excavated and the miners
dug there for gold
however because it was summer and
unbearably hot in the pit
the miners would dig about four feet
along the riverbank
gold dust was mixed in the earth and it
could be separated from the sand by
washing it in river water
there was said to be a secret to the
process
besides gold the miners dug for several
other metals
such as silver copper lead and tin
because of the abundance of gold the
north river area had become
increasingly more wealthy the place was
so prosperous
that evil became a product too many
people organized in gangs and called
themselves
vigilantes under the pretext of helping
the weak
they cheated people out of their money
and in extreme cases
killed them with guns a great many men
were so violent and wayward
that the place was ungovernable
after working for 30 days manjiro and
his friend
received 180 dollars in wages
with the money they quit the agency and
bought their own digging equipment
manjiro earned more than 600 in 70 days
an enormous
sum of money he thought it would be
indecent to continue
he decided to finish up and go to oahu
where he would reconnect with his
friends take passage on a ship
and return home to japan
their ship reached the great harbour of
nagasaki
on september the 29th on the morning of
october the first
they landed and were taken to the
courtyard of the magistrate's office
to be interrogated by the authorities
among the implements the castaways had
brought back with them was a world
map which manjiro used to explain where
they had been
what the different places were like and
other facts about the world
finally the examination was concluded
they were sentenced to three days of
imprisonment
later they were given japanese clothes
and for the first time
their foreheads were shaved in japanese
style
on september the 24th the examination
was finally over
the three men were forbidden to have any
occupation related to the sea
but were compensated with a life-long
stipend and given permission to return
to their home village
denzo's house had crumbled and nobody
could tell where its exact location was
manjiro arrived in nakanohama on the
afternoon of the fifth
to find that his old mother was still
alive
he greeted his elder brother-in-law and
he was greeted by seki
shin and tokizo and his younger brother
and sister
kamikichi and ume they all drank in
celebration
and shed tears on hearing his story of
hardships
[Music]
the world map that manjiro had brought
back had been carefully selected by an
englishman
newly drawn in 1844 of the christian era
the third year of coca no maps the
japanese used could compare with it in
minuteness and perfection
however because the names of the places
had been copied in english and were very
difficult to read
the authorities had manjiro translate
the english words into japanese
for official use by an official
consideration
manjiro was made a hereditary retainer
to the lord
and he gratefully received the favour of
his country
[Music]
you